I have a confession to make
I am a convicted felon
I once went to the movies and I saw a
fire on screen and in my excitement
I yelled out fire
theater
was crowded
I knew it was wrong I knew I had no
First Amendment right to say it
the police immediately came and arrested
me under California's anti-fire in a
crowded theater statement Act of 1989.
I spent ten thousand years in jail but
when I got out of jail I was inspired to
become the lawyer that I am today to
make sure that no one would ever
commit the same First Amendment speech
violations that I did in my younger days
now obviously all of that is complete
nonsense but if you spent any time
online you might not know that if I took
a quick poll and asked you what are you
absolutely 100 not allowed to yell in a
movie theater well everybody knows the
answer to that question and almost
everyone is wrong about that particular
question but don't worry even the people
in government perhaps especially the
people in government who should know
better do not know better let's check in
with New York Governor Kathy hokel yeah
I'll Stand I'll protect the First
Amendment any day of the week but you
don't protect hate speech you don't
protect incendiary speech you're not
allowed to scream fire in a crowded
theater there are limitations on speech
unfortunately we are now all dumber for
having watched that clip the only thing
that we've learned is that the governor
of New York does not understand free
speech at all but luckily I am fired up
to explain how everyone keeps getting
the First Amendment wrong so let's get
this party started now obviously
everyone on the internet thinks you
simply cannot yell fire in a crowded
theater well I am here to tell you that
yes you can generally yell fire in a
crowded theater generally speaking it's
legal say it with me
now this first amendment myth has a long
history that simply will not die and the
origin of it comes from an opinion from
none other than one of the most esteemed
jurists in history Justice Oliver
Wendell Holmes he wrote quote the most
stringent protection of free speech
would not protect a man in falsely
shouting fire in a theater and causing a
panic and millions of Americans across
the decades have decided that this means
you can't yell fire in a crowded theater
Justice Holmes never qualified that the
theater had to be crowded he simply said
that shouting fire when there was no
fire and causing a panic was not
protected speech so why did Holmes
bother to say this were Americans in the
early 1900s constantly pulling hilarious
pranks in which they falsely claimed
that theaters were on fire
oh
uh no not really but deadly theater
fires were common in that particular
time it was standard practice that due
to lacks regulation when all the seats
in the theater were sold out the owners
would seat people in the aisles and
stairways sets and props used to be made
of extremely flammable materials there
wasn't much ventilation and theaters
rarely marked exit doors in 1903 at
least 602 people died in a fire in
Chicago's Iroquois Theater which only
had one entrance Chicago building codes
required separate staircases for every
balcony but the architects who designed
the Iroquois ignored the rules and
instead the theater just had one
staircase so that everyone could see and
be seen regardless of social class and
when the fire broke out the building was
completely full aisles and stairways
were full of theater goers they ran over
each other trying to get through the
front doors and the Iroquois theater
fire was not a unique event there were
so many deadly theater fires that people
genuinely were afraid of crowded spaces
so all this formed the background for
when Justice Holmes wrote his famous
opinion in the 1919 case of shank versus
the United States now you might be
surprised but the facts of the shank
case bear no resemblance to a crowded
theater full of fire phobic patrons now
Charles shank was a socialist who
attempted to distribute thousands of
leaflets encouraging people to evade the
world war one draft the government
charged him with violating the Espionage
Act by conspiring to cause
insubordination in the military and navy
the Supreme Court upheld shank's
conviction and the constitutionality of
the Espionage Act finding that Congress
could regulate speech that created quote
a clear and present danger now all shank
did was send leaflets to recently
conscripted soldiers suggesting that the
draft was a form of involuntary
servitude in violation of the 13th
Amendment and Justice Holmes wrote that
the widespread dissemination of the
leaflets was sufficiently likely to
disrupt the conscription process that
was what gave rise to his so-called
clear and present danger Justice Holmes
conceded that the letter may have been
constitutionally protected in many
places in ordinary times but determined
that the character of the writing quote
depends upon the circumstances which it
is done therefore our homes held quote
the question in every case is whether
the words used are used in such a
circumstance and are of such a nature as
to create a clear and present danger
that will bring about the substantive
evils that Congress has a right to
prevent and in so doing he compared the
leaflets to falsely shouting fire in a
theater provoking a panic the type of
speech that he thought could be
regulated now the clear and present
danger test was favorable to the
government particularly during wartime
when the court gave the government wide
leeway to restrict speech but Justice
Holmes realized his analysis in shank
wasn't very good and was Rife for abuse
and changed his mind within a year in
the case of Abrams versus the United
States another case involving anti-war
activists the Supreme Court upheld
convictions of Russian immigrants who
were charged with violating the Sedition
Act this time though Holmes dissented
from the majority he advocated for a
much more rigorous test arguing that the
government should only be able to punish
speech if there was an imminent danger
that it will bring about the substantive
evils but Shanks clear and present
danger test was eventually over ruled 50
years later when the court replaced it
with the imminent Lawless action test
which protects a broad range of speech
though you might remember it from the
Brandenburg incitement test which um
let's just say it's very relevant these
days so Holmes's analogy was not only
imperfect but it was dicta in the very
case that created it meaning it never
had any force of Law and it was based
out of a case that is simply no longer
good law at all and the problem with the
fire in a crowded theater analogy
generally speaking is that people think
it stands for the proposition that you
can regulate almost any bad speech but
it was a terrible analogy from the the
very Inception and it was used to
regulate speech that was clearly
protected so Pop Quiz when could you
yell fire in a crowded theater well
first of all if there was an actual fire
you would be warning other people so
you're well within your rights to yell
fire when there is a fire in a theater
probably when you mistakenly but in good
faith think that there is a fire even if
there isn't one even if it was false but
you thought there was a fire again you'd
be warning people to try to get to
safety maybe if you needed to get
someone's attention quickly like an
active shooter situation where you need
to concisely convey that people need to
get out of there very quickly maybe when
you were telling a joke if you're a
comedian and it's a punch line to a joke
you can probably yell fire in a crowded
theater if the movie you're watching has
fire in the title or fire on screen or a
script calls for an actor to yell fire
I mean the number of situations where
you could actually yell fire in a
crowded theater probably drown out
situations where you could not yell fire
in a crowded theater that magical phrase
is judged by the exact same First
Amendment standards that we use to judge
every other kind of speech so the
question is did you intend to cause
panic in circumstances likely to cause a
panic and injury well if not then you're
probably in the clear but that takes us
to the second most pervasive Free Speech
myth which is that hate speech is not
free speech well I'm sorry to tell you
that it absolutely is
foreign was too stunned to speak
things that are hateful understandably
make people uncomfortable which is why
even good actors like Lou Diamond
Phillips have bad takes like this let's
all please remember that hate speech is
not free speech it comes with a cost to
real lives let's make kindness our
default setting which is a nice
sentiment but it's also extremely wrong
hate speech is Free Speech according to
the Supreme Court oh wait a minute I'm
getting a breaking news alert according
to the Supreme Court even the Supreme
Court has stated that hate speech is not
protected speech uh well I'm sorry
random Twitter guy but the Supreme Court
has repeatedly ruled that the first
amendment protects even repugnant and
hateful expressions for example the
Court ruled that the Westboro Baptist
Church could protest at the funerals of
dead soldiers carrying signs that say
thank God for dead soldiers and that
have homophobic slurs similarly the
court struck down to Saint Paul
ordinance that made it a crime to place
a burning Cross or swastika anywhere
quote in an attempt to arouse anger or
alarm on the basis of race color creed
or religion the court also ruled that
Nazis could March through the streets of
Skokie Illinois a town where many
Holocaust Survivors lived in other words
hate speech as a part of free speech is
settled law that won't be overturned
anytime soon but if the concept of the
First Amendment having no protections
for hate speech isn't really a thing in
American law then why do so many people
think that hate speech is illegal well
they might be looking at how European
countries regulate speech those other
countries generally don't have the same
kind of First Amendment protections and
after the horrors of World War II many
European nations passed laws
criminalizing speech that incites hatred
or Advocates genocide against certain
groups this is certainly a point of
controversy in the United States where
many many people wish that first
amendment protections did not attach to
what they considered to be hate speech
and you might not like it but in America
the solution to hate speech has
traditionally been in the words of
Justice Louis Brandeis quote more speech
not enforced silence and this might not
please everyone but it's certainly an
easier principle to apply than an
outright ban on hate speech why well
because it's really hard to Define what
constitutes hate speech certainly
president Ron DeSantis would Define hate
speech differently than president
Elizabeth Warren but at least for the
time being if you believe that the
government should be able to regulate
hate speech I'm allowed to call you a
stupid idiot that takes us to the third
myth which involves the application of
the First Amendment to private
corporations the Free Speech Clause of
the First Amendment prohibits quote the
government from abridging the freedom of
speech it does not stop private people
or private corporations from censoring
speech and by that same token whenever
people are complaining about section 230
and the internet and protecting big
corporations almost 100 of the time the
thing that they are upset about is not
section 230 but rather the First
Amendment itself so for example if you
call up a radio show and the host Cuts
you off and hangs up on you your rights
were not violated you can't force the
radio show to give you a platform
similarly if you post misinformation on
Twitter and the company decides that
your Tweet violates their rules they can
ban your account you can't force Twitter
to give you a platform despite how hard
you are trying or if you post a comment
on someone's food blog saying that no
one should ever put pineapple on Pizza
they have a right to delete your comment
even though it is absolutely correct but
again you can't force someone else to
promote your speech and the best way to
think about this dichotomy is by
considering public versus private
schools public schools are an arm of the
government the Supreme Court has said
that public school students quote do not
shed their constitutional rights to
freedom of speech and expression at the
schoolhouse gate students have a limited
right to wear expressive clothing and
hand out petitions as long as they don't
disrupt the functioning of school but
private schools on the other hand do not
give students those same rights because
a private school isn't a state entity
that's a private school
many people believe this is very unfair
but in America the first amendment
protects your expression from intrusion
from the government not from private
corporations when you're talking about
private corporations you always have the
option to take your ball and go home to
leave a popular platform and then create
a platform where no one actually goes
there but at least you can express
yourself and while most people probably
understand this surely it must be the
case that you cannot display profanity
in public with abandon like this
particular Twitter take if you know
someone who is displaying a flag or sign
with profanity you need to report it it
is against the law to have public
profanity in the open even on private
property report them and have the police
have it removed if they refuse file a
lawsuit now this particular bad legal
take involves at least two common myths
one you can't display profanity and two
you can't desecrate the flag well in a
1971 case again involving the draft the
Supreme Court established that the
government cannot criminalize the
display of profane words in public
places in the case of Cohen vs
California Paul Cohen wore a jacket with
the words [__] the draft into an LA
Courthouse police arrested him for
disturbing the peace Cohen was convicted
and sentenced to 30 days in jail an
appeals court affirmed the conviction
because it was foreseeable that wearing
the jacket could cause a violent
reaction as you can see in every era the
US government was really sensitive about
people expressing their desire to avoid
the draft but a closely divided 5-4
Supreme Court reversed the conviction
Justice John Harlan leading the majority
held that the phrase [__] the draft
wasn't an obscenity nor was it fighting
words it couldn't be an obscenity
because the statement wasn't erotic and
it couldn't be fighting words because it
was just a general statement not one
directed at inciting imminent Lawless
action California argued that public
profanity invaded the interests of
unwilling viewers especially women and
children Justice Harlan memorably
observed though that people who were
offended by the jacket quote could
effectively avoid further bombardment of
their sensibilities by averting their
eyes and although some people hate
profanity quote one man's vulgarity is
Another Man's Lyric Justice Harlan also
wrote quote the Constitution leaves
matters of taste and style so largely to
the individual in other words there's no
legal reason you can't just come out and
say Joe Biden rather than let's go
Brandon you cowards and at the same time
if you wanted to you could desecrate the
flag flag desecration includes
everything from burning the American
flag to putting it on a beer bottle
Congress has tried to ban flag
desecration for decades but the Supreme
Court has repeatedly ruled that you have
a First Amendment right to hurt the flag
though in the early 20th century the
Supreme Court did uphold a number of
flag desecration statutes but by the
1960s the court had reverse course for
example when civil rights leader James
Meredith was shot in Mississippi in 1966
Sydney Street took his own flag into the
street in New York City and lit it on
fire Street a black veteran of World War
II said quote if they can do this to
James Meredith we don't need a flag the
city fine Street a hundred dollars
Street filed a lawsuit and eventually it
reached the Supreme Court and the
Supreme Court reversed Street's
conviction it held that street could not
be punished for burning the flag then in
1974 the court reversed the conviction
of a college student who put a peace
sign on the flag the state prosecuted
the student under a law that made it
illegal to improperly use the flag in
this case the Supreme Court rule told
that this was a symbolic speech that was
protected by the First Amendment and
when the court reversed a flag-burning
conviction in 1989 the Senate and
President George H.W bush were outraged
and Congress enacted the flag protection
Act protesters responded by immediately
burning flags and they were convicted
under federal law but the Supreme Court
struck that law down in the United
States versus Eichmann holding that
quote if there is a Bedrock principle
underlying the First Amendment it is
that the government may not prohibit the
expression of an idea simply because
Society finds the idea itself offensive
or disagreeable though if you go out
there and exercise your right to
truthfully yell fire in a crowded
theater or burn a bunch of flags in the
street you'll probably build up quite
the appetite in today's sponsor Factor
75 can help with that because Factor
makes meeting your nutrition goals
easier than ever by delivering fresh
never Frozen dietitian improved meals
right to your doorstep and the meals are
completely ready to eat eliminate hours
it would take to shop meal prep and cook
so you can spend your time doing things
that you actually want to do because
Factory meals arrive pre-prepared and
ready to eat in just two minutes in the
same amount of time that I could think
about going to the grocery store my
factory meal is already done and it's
surprisingly affordable factors team of
gourmet chefs creates each meal using
only ingredients with Integrity to make
you feel your best and they really are
extremely delicious Factor supports
wholesome eating Made Simple their menus
are updated weekly with 34 different
options choose your favorite meals or
let Factor craft your order based on
your taste preferences and meal history
Factor takes the guesswork out of
grocery shopping and meal prep saving
you time and energy for other things
factors no hassle prepared foods make
sure that you always have something
nutritious on hand when you don't have
time to think about making a meal and
sometimes I just want a good healthy
meal without having to cook so give
factor a try by going to factor75.com
and use the code legal eagle 50 to get
50 off your first Factor box or just
click on the link that's on screen right
now or down in the description and use
the code legal eagle 50 to get 50 off
your first Factor box after that click
on this link over here for more legal
eagle or I'll see you in court